you can have Aunt May as like a
spider-man figure Kraven is looking for
the perfect prey so hunting one
spider-man is not enough Roger Rabbit
ask there's cartoons there's real people
Tom Holland can be in it too I guess
[Music]
I'm Rita Mastro sitting in for Phillip
Melina because I've trapped him in the
blue dungeon and so he's staying there
for a while today we're talking about
going back into the spider-verse with me
to walk through those spider webs is
Eric Foss yes on this episode we're
gonna predict what creepy things are
gonna happen in dr. sleep but first into
the spider verse to this week we got our
first teaser for the sequel to of the
oscar-winning spider-man into the
spider-verse animated movie right the
teaser didn't show us much but it did
give us just enough to wildly speculate
about the plot of the sequel so give me
your best rogue theories for what's
gonna happen in the second into the
spider burst movie Eric okay I'm gonna
jump on this grenade first over two
years from now but my thing is so the
one voice actor who they have confirmed
for it other than you know the Miles
Morales character is Hailee Steinfeld as
Gwen Stacy thank you yeah so I think
this movie's gonna be all about Gwen
Stacy and what I would love to see is
what if like the whole first act of the
movie is just like a filled out version
of that prologue for Gwen Stacy that we
gotten into the spider-verse
and the next movie is gwen stacy story
because we know that like the sony
spider-verse wants to pursue gwen stacy
as like her own character with her own
like world of characters around you
should by the way wednesday Anna's
costume thank you for committing to
putting up your Christmas lights and I
refuse to believe it's already November
disclosure we had an email accidentally
go out that we copied and pasted last
week so Daniel is the only one to
actually read it Foley did not question
when they told me that this was the
Halloween episode
let's blame off-screen producer Zach
off-screen so my gwen stacy movie if
this is the next movie I want to see all
the other spider-verse characters that
are it could be in her band at the
mary-jane so maybe you have like a
Jessica drew spider woman you could have
a Cindy moon spider person you could
have may as like a spider-man figure
it's like playing a band like she plays
drums in the Mary Jane's and like let's
see her world and like build out the
world from her perspective and then
maybe like throughout the movie it could
be like her friendship with Miles
Morales maybe something more with Miles
Morales and we see how that evolves and
then like the the movie can be kind of
like a rom-com between the two of them
within the drama of this like
spider-verse world with everyone else
trying to be like no we have a bigger
drama to fight and they just want to be
like teenagers or young adults and
what's like rom-com is like romantic
comedy but like what's wrong calm action
like because obviously there's gonna be
action too like rom-com wrong rom-com
boom boom my theory has no romance but a
bunch of hunks for my theory though
all right you would but she stopped you
I am gonna be awarding rogue ease to
everybody for their theories but
Danielle effectively blocked Erik from
getting his very okay so it stays over
here is a little hostage and at the end
whoever gets the most Roby's according
to my arbitrary decision making gets
their wishes granted and these wishes
have written I've already been written
out so they know what they've done but
we don't and at the end one of those
wishes will come true live on screen so
it's gonna be great so Erik try not to
[ __ ] up so badly next time
okay fair enough Danielle please contend
oh okay so my hunky spider-man into the
spider-verse - yeah the hunky part is
gonna be part of the title now mattress
yes
done in okay so I'm thinking that those
live-action
spider-man's better men spider-man Mans
we're gonna make a kind of make an
appearance in spider-man - the one and
only spider-man in my heart Tobey
Maguire should definitely be the lead of
this spider-man into the spider-verse
unit spider-verse honestly I had a hard
time it's not but it is okay I'm
thinking like a Roger Rabbit ask there's
cartoons there's real people Tom Holland
can be in it too I guess
mostly Tobey Maguire and here with the
cartoons and they have got to save all
of the different spider-man universes
from being erased you know what Who
Framed Roger Rabbit is like one of the
best movies I mean that's the main of
the biggest crossover see that PSA that
they've told us like not to do drugs in
the early 90s and the Ninja Turtles were
in it and I feel like a lot of their
friend Roger forgetting about that
amazing I'm not forgetting it gonna be
mashing up those worlds more of the
Spider Men man's joining in they all got
a band together and make sure none of
the spider verses get amazing yeah that
is like Who Framed Roger because it like
toontown was being paved oh yeah and
it's like and just like how each new
spider-man story that comes out kind of
like us to let go of the Andrew Garfield
and for some people they don't know the
Sam Raimi spider-man movies as much
because now they have Tom Holland right
now it can like dig into that whole like
meta issue of like which is the truest
spider-man and is there gonna be dip in
this movie because then all the animated
spider-man's can be erased with dip yeah
from Roger Rabbit get on the same
there was your roadie waiting for you
and you didn't get on the same page as
me but Roger Rabbit so can we at least
have at the end of this Kenda and you
can Andrew Garfield be dipped
I I'm going off of how the last movie
ended with spider-man
was at 2099 yeah Miguel O'Hara yeah so
he had a little weird watch thing so I
think that's how the villain is going to
show up and one of the most recent comic
book storylines Kraven the hunter
decided to collect all of any superhero
that wasn't had an animal name and then
hunt all of them because he was looking
for like the perfect prey and I like the
idea that Kraven is looking for the
perfect prey so hunting one spider-man
is not enough he found finds that little
bracelet thing and he now wants to go to
every single universe and hunt every
spider-man yeah cuz then he could go to
Tobey Maguire's and then
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Music]
but they do yeah
have you ever won I did win once I think
Philip felt a little guilty okay okay
before we move on to talk about dr.
sleep let's take a moment to shout out
some of the cool stuff that we have
happening here and new rock stars
hey everyone Eric here and with Rick and
Morty coming back soon we can announce a
new series called Rick's plane it will
be our official Rick and Morty
after-show as special guests from the
Rick and Morty staff you can access it
by subscribing to our Rick's plane
podcast feed and we're calling it Rick's
plane because if it's one thing Rick and
Morty fans love it's splainin to their
friends with each episode the really a
brow if you have ever wondered if mr.
meeseeks is a metaphor for slavery or if
pickle rick is an analogy for painkiller
addictions no you are not overthinking
it you're just broken the way I am
because each episode I'm gonna dive deep
into the black hole of an episode of
Rick and Morty the news season 4
episodes and leading up to that standout
episodes from seasons 1 2 & 3
to decode how each is a secret right for
help and each episode yeah I'm gonna be
sitting down with special guests from
the show writers voice actors animators
so that they can confirm whether or not
my Rick's planation is legit and give us
some secrets behind these episodes that
we otherwise would never know so
subscribe to Rick's planed wherever you
get your podcasts so of all the Rick and
Morty bands you know you to be the Rick
is Rick I want to point out that the
message board that we have here in the
back of the rogue Theory set each week
will pick a new patreon member at random
and let them put whatever they want on
the sign whatever they want you know
staying reasonable so this week we
picked Riley Jay Harris and he put I
love this channel 3000 which is a boss
it's in the game
um all future messages should just Stoke
Eric's ego as much as God so become a
patron and get to put up your own
message great yeah Eric cuz he's never
gonna win no this the sequel to The
Shining comes out this week oh wow yeah
yes and we all love The Shining except
Stephen King mostly it's just who's
funny we all love this reading so much
so that Eric recently did a full movie
breakdown of it that you can find on our
patreon page we're going to predict some
of the things that might happen in the
doctor sleep movie and you can google
the plot of the book so you know we're
gonna kind of focus on predictions
rather than stuff that you can just look
up online and the person who gets the
best prediction can get their picture on
the wall their head shot that it's gonna
replace mine because mine's been up
there since I very very accurately
predicted the end of the El Camino movie
I did it perfectly the what did anyone
see that it's very good and the people
in this room side so I got my picture up
in the wall but if you guys if your
predictions for the doctor sleep movie
are the most accurate then your picture
will replace mine and that will go back
where it started which is on my fridge
so I can guarantee mine will not exactly
so first question this is a very
important question will someone have sex
with a guy in a bear costume very
important very important I'm gonna say
no even though it is in Stephen King's
book it was a dog costume in the book it
was the manager of the hotel
Harry Derwent and what was a lover's
name whatever um but no I don't think
there might be a dog costume I don't
think there will be a bear costume
though oh so it's just a little nod
someone will be having sex with a dog
costume you were joking just the costume
first leaping back yes I think there
should be sex with a bear because
walking around West Hollywood on
Halloween the midsummer couple was like
the hot costume when it was like what is
going on in your I don't know about
anyone else but personally I found that
bear mask to be the most terrifying
aspect of shiny I still have nightmares
about it but I think someone's
definitely gonna have sex with a bear
costume nobody's on the floor everybody
gets a Rogi for that no one gets the
road like having to trade back the baby
rhino you poached guys next question
next question number two will the weird
9/11 subplot show up in dr. sleep hmm I
mean it did play a big part in the book
I know you're not talking about the book
but I mean you have knowledge so yeah no
it did play a big part in establishing a
bruh Eric tur which is the little girl
in the movie and book but also it was
2003 so not that yeah not that 9/11
still isn't like a big deal obviously
it's a big deal obviously but like 2003
was there it was on every fresh yeah so
maybe she predicted Trump will be
present I am NOT coming no one could
predict it yeah but maybe not 9/11 I
don't know maybe another Lucy you think
okay yeah so it might still be political
but you're yeah we're like I don't know
some fictional something just that she
has precognition in general yeah yeah
absolutely
that makes sense I think it's going to
be hinted at but not said explicit I
think you're going to yeah there's gonna
be an easter egg showing like cult shows
up at Ground Zero memorial or something
just an odd respectful gesture for the
fans of 9/11 taking place and crazy baby
rhinos everything turns to chaos
yeah Jeff I just feel 911 that's such a
bummer so I don't want to be number
three what Stephen King universe
reference will be made because there's a
lot there's a lot to choose from here so
feel like they're really trying to flesh
out that whole universe I feel like they
might end up in dairy oh oh yeah oh nice
because they're close geographically
right yeah Dan ends up in I'm not main
somewhere in the north of you and you're
like that in the book yeah and so I feel
like might as well be dairy yeah they
want to make it eat or if it's like the
town over from there or something where
it just gets mentioned Bangor anytime I
have a chance to say Bangor correctly
cuz I said Bangor and it's not right
Bangor Maine yeah I feel like that might
be a really subtle yeah that fun little
Easter Egg they can sneak in there
without having to really go cheap into
yeah exactly that's fun
yeah I think when
he returns to the Overlook because I
believe he goes back to the he's going
to pull over in a small town and Kathy
Bates is gonna be there and she's a huge
fan of novels in misery he's on his way
back from the Overlook so I think they
might throw in Kathy Bates I'm gonna I'm
gonna throw in there that he's flying
back to the Overlook and there's a
lightning storm and the Langille here
come and eat him they could have made it
you get one Jeff and you do too is gonna
take this person I did you know what I
did like that but I'm out of tiny
rookies so why not just give me a buzz
then you'll get a big number for will
anyone say here's Johnny in the sequel
will they will they won't they I think
will be funny if it's just like they're
looking for some other lost child and
they're like where is he weird and then
just someone goes oh they make a quick
stop at Starbucks on their way just like
twitching yeah I don't think I think
they're gonna update it to the modern
era and it's someone's got a break
through the door and say welcome welcome
welcome
[Laughter]
good and everybody just for fun give me
your best here's Johnny it doesn't have
to be accurate but it could be as
another character it could be your
yourself as Jack Nicholson just give me
your best one yes you can
[Music]
so mine is this is a Wednesday Adam
train here's Johnny the choice I'm
making is a young child actor who is
trying to do them like a line or a
monologue for an audition not knowing
the context of great can we actually
have you take that again but more
serious okay well contact you thank you
thank you so much for doing great but
the but the scariest one was yours
everybody recap their Rogie scores for
me okay so I have three and a quarter
roadies okay for roadies I have three
and a quarter so there's still a chance
for anybody to win because now it's time
for the final section rogue questions
yes so these are questions
no occupants dude okay so these
questions are a rapid-fire and they have
never seen these questions before so
it's anyone's game and I will be
awarding points at my leisure question
number one at Martin Scorsese continues
to stick by his comments dissing
superhero movies
what else is Martin Scorsese probably
totally wrong about anybody how to end
Gangs of New York
Sopranos music and do the stupid time
lapse of 1860s New York to modern day
it's like to tell all the Bros in New
Jersey and Long Island
hey this gang violence that you see Pony
and his friends do every week Brando's
ends oh I really hated that loved the
movie yeah it's amazing
I think he's just wrong he's probably
wrong about like even like texting he
probably like his taxes like sincerely
Martin Scorsese he's still sharing stuff
on Facebook you know yeah because he did
that very long very good accent yeah all
right next question
great James Jean is going to appear in a
movie 64 years after his death what dead
performer would you like to see in a
superhero movie and why I'd like to see
Prince in a because he was like in part
of Batman with his music I'd like to see
him if they could like you know work
some witchcraft and resurrect him was
kind of close to that I was gonna say
Michael Jackson and the real thriller
situation terrified I'm gonna go with a
complete opposite I wanted like
resurrect Paul Lynde deep fake him and
make them sound crazy villains like I'm
gonna get ya
I was Captain Marvel star brie Larson
dressed as Britney Spears for Halloween
give me your best superhero theme did
Britney Spears parodies let's go say
he's so Bucky that is exactly what the
question was
I think the wire has a beautiful blonde
hair yeah
goes full Britney Spears shave goes to
the goes to those 11 oh yeah with the
bald shaved head in a breakdown for sure
I'm gonna base mine on Iron Man sings
oops created a villain great so now
everybody count up your rogue E's and
tell me who the winner is because I am
NOT great at counting I have five and a
quarter Wow I too have five and a
quarter really a tiebreaker tiebreaker
yet you know what I'm gonna do with the
tiebreaker myself Erik give me a rocky
of yours okay and then you get both of
these because you work us to you great
so that's it for this episode of rogue
theory but Danielle won so she gets a
wish so Jeff your wish does not come
true
Erik your wish does not come true my
first wish ever that's ever gonna come
true
Danielle you win so no I should not have
made you in your wish is that everyone
has to be wednesday addams next week and
I have dug myself with her and now it
was
clearly fits me better okay well that's
it for this episode of rogue theory
thanks for wroking with us and thanks to
our guests for coming
Jeff Danielle no thanks to Eric and give
me your where can we follow you guys
what's going on with you guys obviously
follow me vas you can see me on the
channel we got some exciting Rick and
Morty content coming out special guests
we're going back to look at some
previous episodes one may already be on
the channel but on Sunday is the Rick
and Morty season premiere so we'll do a
breakdown of that I'm gonna do an
after-show special guest and also we're
gonna look at some like we're gonna
re-watch some of the Star Wars original
movies maybe we break down some of those
wow that's great I just got with the hip
kids and got a Twitter this year oh you
can follow me now on Twitter at Mick
spice o MC SPI SS oh maybe I can get
into double digit followers with all
those roadies you can do anything and
you can follow me on instagram at evil
Jeff or my podcast comic-book queers
which we discuss comic books but mostly
all things x-men ads comic book queers
thanks for coming thanks for being here
thanks for talking about having sex with
bear costumes um don't forget to
subscribe to rogue theory to the podcast
because it comes out before these
episodes join YouTube follow us on
Twitter at new rock stars and follow me
at Marina masterís and I'll get Philip
out of the dungeon when I feel like it
[Applause]
[Music]